si les mains avec la sortie aujourd'hui
de wanted un film canadien au casting
prestigieux écoutez bien gérard
depardieu renaud johnny pour la première
fois réunis à l'écran
marie-jo jouant guillaume fera dans la
série brochette culte mercenaires
samouraï ou cavaliers de l'apocalypse
en voici une qui risque de devenir
célèbre à l'insu de son plein gré entre
pieds nickelés et tonton flingueur
décimé le bétail et nos plus grandes
têtes d'affiché en truand ringard envoyé
aux têtes pour un braquage facile mais
une petite erreur de cible et et voilà
chez le chef de la mafia de chicago
avant tout un film devient complice je
me suis bien amusé parce qu'en plus j'ai
trouvé que tous ces gens étaient d'une
honnêteté totale alors ça ça me plaît à
part moi les autres sont très bon tiers
[ __ ]
pas sûr car non en petits casseurs nommé
07 une fois que c'est un mec un peu
barge complètement cinglé même qui aime
bien tiré les coups de feu à tour de
bras à touba qui parle de lui à la
troisième personne du singulier moment
d'anthologie mais truand marcel et 0
sont bien sûr fans de johnny et de
renault vi lui
arrêtez vos paris et les acteurs ne sont
pas doublés voire même le poissonnier ou
sur les marchés sauf albert dré paul
samanos rendu attachant grâce aux
acteurs à voir comme une curiosité